aussi connu de gros problèmes avec un
producteur qui a voulu tarnac et tu as
été contacté par le site my major
company qui est ainsi très sérieux vous
avez accumulé près de 100000 euros dans
une cagnotte participative afin de
produire ton nouvel album
c'est grâce à cet argent tu as pu
commencer à enregistrer quelques chants
quelques chansons mais très vite naples
une nouvelle de ces deux des équipes du
producteur oui oui c'est quand tu as
essayé de reprendre contact avec eux et
ont dit qu'ils avaient versé l'argent a
lancé une équipe dont il a pris les cent
mille hommes 16 boul c'est ça exactement
- en fait à partir du moment où donc
j'ai reçu la cagnotte j'ai fait quelques
sessions studio et puis du jour au
lendemain mais je n'arrivais plus à voir
mon équipe donc mon producteur my major
company était la plateforme sur lequel
on peut y ait pas d'amalgamé quiproquos
et du coup voilà le temps passe et je
n'arrivais plus à les joindre
my major pareil voilà on n'arrive plus à
voir ton équipe et c'est passé deux ans
comme ça et ça on va voir comment tu
faisais pourtant sortir financièrement
hamas a été exagérément chaud on a été
très très difficile quand tu passes
comme ça parce que tu es tu as vendu des
digues des millénaires il ya un moment
tu avais du mal à voilà ça a été dur à
c'est sûr qu'il a eu la même vie au jour
le jour
j'ai eu une vie qui a été très sympa
l'effigié musique a été plus difficile
mais très honnêtement c'est même pas ça
le problème
je ne regrette même pas d'avoir connu
cette période parce que maintenant ça
m'a renforcé
j'ai connu ce que c'est que la vraie vie
et je pense que pour mon prochain album
sa mort a beaucoup inspiré de vivre ce
soir comme ça
alors